beef cheeks just think the size of your
little cheeks yeah imagine the size of a
cow with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah
i want you to give them a really nice
season with salt and pepper on there
please so beef cheeks very cheap i cut
that takes sort of a long time to cook
yeah but give it a bit of love let it
cook in the oven
it comes out like a dream
a little touch
of oil in the pan what you want to do
is get them really nicely colored sid
sid into the pan
oh cool
lay away
you see what that is um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
the beach
baby
and then i want the onion chunky because
i'm gonna cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
down
down
and then again there
and there so it doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at
our restaurants if they take so long
they go in the oven literally half past
six seven o'clock in the morning three
and a half four hours to be ready for
lunch and the longer you leave them in
their juices
and the cooking liquor the better three
nice cloves of garlic good onions in and
garlic in please
nice where's your baby there it is good
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored put the
cheeks back in please
right red wine in cool okay and the red
wine is going to deglaze the pan so
delays will basically sort of
rinse
all that flavor off the bottom of the
pan yeah okay because that's going to
make the most amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes you'll make a
much better sauce i'm going to top that
with some stock so the secret braising
is having little of the meat exposed and
90 of it submerged see them now yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water
turn the gas off and leave the lid
just off at the end there if we had to
cover it completely
the steam hits the top yeah the lid and
all that water comes very badly solar
still that's right in the oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
boom
for pudding i'm making one of my
absolute favorite italian desserts
banacotta with that quintessentially
italian flavoring espresso
[Music]
start by immersing two leaves of
gelatine in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream
milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
[Music]
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
[Music]
squeeze out the soaked gelatine leaves
and stir into the hot cream until
completely dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your moulds just short of the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
[Music]
leave in the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
[Music]
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour caster sugar into a pan and cook
over medium heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel
dust with ground cinnamon and leave to
set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm giving
each mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
[Music]
dress with a shard of crunchy hazelnut
brittle nothing could be so deliciously
elegant
right captain jack quick run through
panna cotta's are nearly set beef cheeks
are nearly cooked we're going to now do
the fig and crostini oh okay let's take
the figs we're going to make a nice
slightly spicy
fig jam
take all the tops yeah in half and each
half into three
sugar the touch of salt in there
okay we're making a jam but we don't
want to be too sweet and then these
little babies
what are they
ah
what's the shape
stars star niche meat it's tarnished
taken from the hennessy plant yeah when
you dry them like that so intensifies
the flavor really important to count how
we put in there okay yeah so one two
three four five so they're just there
for a flavor and then you take them out
that's right
secret here let's get that camo going so
when i hear of jam i don't think of
caramel
no but this is a very fast jam caramel's
starting to color
i want you very carefully to drop
the figs in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the caramel
you know what that is well sweet vinegar
i love that on my salad you've got that
sort of sweet and sour flavor leave that
cooking for three four minutes
now let's slice our chipotle in italian
crostini means little bits of toast
but it can be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread
we're staying authentically italian with
ciabatta
season them
and then drizzle
a little touch of olive oil on there
both sides really important because
we're going to grill the bread
push it down
put some lovely very lovely take it off
with the chipata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star in these pods
from our piping hot fig jam
my jacket we've got one little bugger to
find oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
some of the skin's disintegrated in that
camera that looks so nice
while jack carefully spreads the
crostini with our hot fig jam i can
unveil the last element to our starter
the creamy italian speciality burrata
a little money bags
they can delicious
this looks fun doesn't it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest can you imagine that
sat there
and you tear some of it off when you
stick it on top of that
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks i've chosen to use
papridelli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salting first good
olive oil in
pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it no
bring that back up the ball that's going
to take about three
for four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yup and chop him now wait to see these
beef cheeks
beauties
at them
oh look soft they're very soft tiny want
to taste
that's so good
oh jack you just dribbled on your jumper
joke
really
right drain
the pasta
salt pepper
pasta
little drizzle
of olive oil
i'm going to put your fresh pasta nicely
chopped nicely chopped
in
this is the magic bit okay you take
a little ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom
and you put
the pasta on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
gonna love you even more now you know
uh what about when you cook this with
your girlfriend one day
uh just tell her where you got the
recipe from william promise promise i
don't want you stealing daddy's thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there
two beautiful jaws on there
and then the third
jaw and then you go over
with the sauce
how cool is that delicious
you've got the porra
i've got the cheeks
let's go please
[Music]
my ultimate italian dinner
quick thick jam crostini with creamy
borata
a main course of slow cooked beef cheek
ragu with papadely
and for pudding espresso panna cotta
with cinnamon hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best italian
tradition
first things first i'd like you to
season the stewing steak
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah
good girl what's the flour going to do
dad the flour helps to brown the beef
our seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew
i feel a bit like marshmallows
they do feel a little bit marshmallow
don't they look at the size of the
chunks of the beef
i'm going to cut my carrots literally
similar similar size that's right does
that mean they'll cook equally that's
right
now these
are little pearl onions i'm gonna put
them in hole as well
everything
has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burn garlic before
oh matilda
she promised you weren't gonna mention
that
what is that
time
time and what they
bay leaves bailey's good girl
tablespoon of oil in
the beef goes in first okay
[Music]
got a beautiful color
remember the carrots thyme in
could go
garlic
purl onions in
good
give that a really good mix up
[Music]
easy to make daddy stews are very easy
to make providing at the beginning you
give it a little bit of love
now that's all beautifully browned
that thing that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan
adding beer or stout helps to tenderize
the beef and give it a hearty delicious
flavor
and that's the only way i want you to
taste beer
in a stew
yeah
i'm going to add in a couple of
teaspoons of tomato puree please
in fact three please
because it's so nice
and there's one final thing in there
cover this chewing steak with the beef
stock give that a little mix with daddy
please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you
serve it oh yes is the garlic going to
be burnt no excuse me right and we
always put the lid with a little bit
just a little bit so it can breathe
that's right i cannot make the stew all
watery into the oven at 150 please teals
for about two and a half hours and now
you can focus on your
homework fun
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato classics in one twice baked
bubble and squeeze jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute in butter and add a dash of
water until tender
[Music]
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and cook
through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato center
then mash with a couple of knobs of
butter mix in the cabbage and season to
taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
right homework done yeah beef stew is
chewing stewing let's get on with our
delicious hearty pet art i've been
looking forward to this
you and i chef i'm gonna prep the pears
so if you peel
i'll top and tail
into quarters pears go soft in the oven
very very quickly so we're gonna put
them on a tart you'll need to leave them
whole half or in quarter
what's that in there ginger that's right
a stem ginger so you stem ginger and
fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup good girl and some
brown sugar to your quartered pears
then just grab some fresh ginger off you
go so it's a bit of a um different one
to grate this because it doesn't really
come through like the cheese no
i'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there
right what we need to do now is give
that
a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff where you make it it's so
easy to do
so give me your finger
that's my center point i want you to get
the pears going around
like that a really nice circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pears keep on sliding all over the place
yeah so egg wash the outside and i'm
going to show you a little trick
so you lift that up so see egg wash
acting like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
and the pastry forms this nice little
shelf like a little money bag are you
going to do anything with the spare
pairs oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
ginger
let me go around mike with your glue
we might glue just on top
tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelises it and colors the pears
beautifully it's a bit like snow isn't
it now that glazes the pastry so the
pastry has this really nice shine on
there as well finally the lemon on top
and then put that there
180 and in she goes
you smell the beef smells delish
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it look at that i want you to
just i was hoping you'd ask just have a
little taste
[Music]
how's that taste now
i'm not allowed um
all right
dumpling time flour in please i'm using
self-raising flour for a fluffy result
but if you like your dumplings hard use
plain flour
next the dumpling essential suet
that makes the dumplings nice and moist
thank you
followed by a generous dollop of grain
mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers around and
i've got a touch of warm water here
your fingers are now a nice little whisk
your fingers are getting tired right now
put your hand in there now you should
bring
all that dough together
i'll show you the best way to get that
nice and clean sprinkle the flour on
your hands rub them together
all that will come off
that's a good way isn't it now we've got
this wonderful dumpling mixture
how squidgy is that
a little flour on your hands okay
roll these lengthways
and then i want you to
fall in like that in your hand
off we go
smell that mustard in there
huh
yes please
silly
gently
let's go in
at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
and put that back into the oven for 20
minutes to cook the dumplings now if you
open the door for daddy i'm going to
take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our pet art has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby that looks good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please
nice and gently all the way around good
girl
little taps
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job
now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look
delicious okay i'll check on the
dumplings
now
look
they've sort of doubled in size
whoa definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
i might have to have a quick taste
before we go just to check i mean we
don't have to be sure we have to be very
sure
[Music]
that is an amazing hearty beef stew with
dumplings right the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate hearty dinner
a comforting rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and ginger galette
you